thank you
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story tonight a robotic vehicle
Dives back into the Atlantic to recover
more debris from the sub where five
people died exploring the Titanic
as Canada launches its investigation
into what happened this stepson of one
of the victims tells Sky News he held
out hope right to the very end
I was so focused on those moments of how
special it would be to be with him again
and unfortunately you know our our
hearts were broken
also tonight the treasury and Bank
bosses agree to measures to help ease
the burden of rising mortgage repayments
but will it be enough to help struggling
homeowners there will be a minimum
12-month period before there's a
repossession without consent
so we do think of the next six to eight
months that the number of calls from
potentially distressed customers is
going to increase
a man is found guilty of murdering a
police officer inside a police station
we have a special report from Europe's
second biggest Reservoir now reduced to
a desert and Ukrainian towns drying up
after the attack on the kakovka dam
[Music]
plus we go to worthy Farm where
Glastonbury Festival is well underway
with some special guests
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages and I'll press
preview that's coming up from 10 30 this
evening
[Music]
hello there very good evening to you the
investigation has begun tonight into why
the submersible Titan could have
imploded while exploring the Titanic
Canada has announced the launch of its
probe into the Canadian Flagship the
polar Prince which carried the sub and
today a stream of family and friends
have paid tribute to the five men who on
board as well as a course of criticism
for the company Ocean Gate but its
co-founder has defended the Expedition
and ocean Gates CEO
while on Sunday at 8am the submersible
began its 13 000 foot descent to the
Titanic wreckage about 400 miles off the
coast of Newfoundland it lost
Communications with its Mothership the
polar Prince an hour and 45 minutes
later now the U.S Navy says at the same
time their network of underwater sensors
detected an anomaly consistent with an
implosion or explosion in the area the
submersible failed to surface at its
scheduled time of 3 P.M and almost three
hours later the U.S Coast Guard received
a report of the missing submersible and
its five passengers Crews from the
United States Canada and France joined
the search which spanned an area about
the size of Northern Ireland on
Wednesday debris was found 16 000 feet
from the wreckage of the Titanic
containing pieces of the Titan
submersible it was then confirmed that
all the crew died Sky's U.S
correspondent James Matthews reports now
from Boston as the search for more parts
of the sub continues
the tourist traffic continues off North
America's Coast these were whale
watchers leaving Boston the benign end
of Atlantic attractions
adventure's Other Extreme had occupied
this City's Coast Guard this week
there was no news today for them to
report the day before had drawn a line
under their hunt and hope for a
submersible missing at sea
this is video from 2021 of the Titan
submersible with a guided tour from the
man behind it two years after these
pictures were filmed Stockton Rush would
be among the five who died on board and
all the lead down here can be dropped in
an absolute emergency so you can get to
the surface amidst questions over safety
his words then have a dark Echo no I'd
like to be remembered as an innovator
um I think it was General MacArthur said
you remembered for the rules you break
and you know I've broken some rules to
make this there has been criticism of
the man who built the Titan and its
carbon fiber designs but there is also
support from a co-founder of his company
he was a talented engineer he's very
intelligent person who's a passionate
Explorer but mostly he was a keen risk
manager he was very well aware of the
risks of operating at these deep depths
and he was very committed to safety U.S
Navy listening gear underneath the waves
picked up the sound of an implosion as
the Titan made its descent towards the
Titanic there will be investigations
into exactly what happened how and why
for now we're learning more about who
was on board the five who perished
nineteen-year-old Suleiman dawood died
with his father on board the Titan his
aunt said the student had been scared of
the trip but didn't want to disappoint
his father shazada on a Father's Day
weekend
the British billionaire Hamish Harding
was described by his family as a boy who
grew to be a dedicated father a man who
lived for his next adventure pull on
renergally the French navy veteran on
board was remembered by his stepson
earless
um this is warm uh bursts of energy I
always got from being with him he's this
incredible human being I mean we can you
know talk forever about his impact in
the ocean but for me the impact was
mostly felt out of the ocean out at Sea
this was the Odyssey 6K one of the
remotely operated vehicles that
discovered debris from the Titan
submersible that search is continuing
Canada's Transportation safety board has
launched an investigation
this was the scene at Newfoundland in
Canada from where the submersible set
sail towards the site with a Titanic
sank in 1912. on the North Atlantic
Shore they honor the victims of the
disaster that followed disaster James
Matthews Sky News in Boston
well our International correspondent
John Sparks joins us now live from
Newfoundland and Joanna as we were just
talking there the mothership polar
Prince is expected to arrive sometime
tomorrow where you are and we also know
that a Canadian investigation has now
begun it seems to be a long and very
complex process ahead
yeah I think that's right Emma this
investigation either first of several
I'm sure potentially many investigations
lodged by the Transportation safety
board of Canada it will investigate the
incident from the perspective of the
Polar prints that's the supply ship that
put the submersible Titan in the water
last Sunday and it loaded up it was it
went out to see with 17 crew members 24
in total it will as you say return
tomorrow with five less people the
safety board they can only investigate
this incident from the perspective of
that ship because the submersible
doesn't count as a proper vessel as a
proper ship and that is one way that
Stockton Rush the founder of Ocean Gate
was able to sidestep the regulations the
safety board will investigate it and
they will produce a report which aims to
improve Transportation safety in Canada
that's the objective here can also tell
you that we understand a new ROV Mission
has been launched rovs are these
remotely operated Vehicles this one
provided by a company from Cape Cod in
the United States it's this vehicle that
found the debris field near the Titanic
on Thursday and alerted the world to the
uh the fate of the people on board this
time it's going down to document the
area and assist in any direct recovery
of debris interesting that direct
recovery
I'm sure they will be looking for the
bodies and I'm sure that there is a
conversation going on about if they find
them whether they're brought back to the
surface and I think this this incident
this story it tells us something about
the collective pull on the Titanic
on on everybody and particularly on some
individuals who are prepared to go to
extraordinary lengths to see it in
person in the flesh and I think there
will be a conversation about whether it
is necessary to do this to visit what is
and if so whether there are better ways
to do this safely
we'll leave it there for now John Sparks
live in St John's Harbor in Newfoundland
thank you
now the news tonight the child said
Jeremy Hunt met with leaders of Summer
Britain's biggest banks including
Lloyd's NatWest Barclays and virgin
money today it follows a decision by the
bank of England to hike interest rates
to five percent in an effort to try to
get inflation under control while these
are the measures lenders and the
chancellor agreed that people should be
given a 12-month break before
repossession proceedings begin
homeowners will also be able to change
their mortgage to interest only and
switch back to their original deal
within six months with no impact to
their credit score and those struggling
with repayments will be allowed to speak
to their lender to discuss payment
options without it having any impact on
their credit rating sky as Matthew
Thompson has more
Newport is no stranger to hard times but
with interest rates soaring they're
about to get harder places like this
where incomes are already stretched will
be amongst the worst affected this local
mortgage broker is already seeing signs
of distress so we do think in the next
six to eight months that the number of
calls from potentially distressed
customers is going to increase mainly
due to the fact that there's 1.4 million
people who are currently on fixed rate
deals which may be historic under two
percent deals
coming out onto potentially six percent
or higher
economists predict that 1.2 million
people will go bust this year as a
direct result of higher mortgage
payments the biggest impacts will be
felt here in Wales and also in the
northeast of England but right across
the country people will be pushed to the
brink people like Benjamin who despite a
decent household income will still
struggle
1400 a month and that'll be going up to
2 500 a month so 1100 extra obviously
our electric bills have gone up a couple
of hundred quid our Foods customers is
30 40 more a week
um you know we just don't have that sort
of money spare every month so basically
stuck you know cats all the house to get
rid of the mortgage can't pay the
mortgage amount so I don't know what
we're going to do in a month's time when
it comes to the end of the existing
thing
[Music]
today after a meeting with the
chancellor Banks agreed to provide more
support people who are at risk of losing
their home in that extreme situation the
banks and mortgage lenders have a number
of things in place it's the last thing
that they want to do to repossess a home
but in that extreme situation they've
agreed there will be a minimum 12-month
period before there's a repossession
without consent labor unsurprisingly is
Keen to point the finger at the
government they're going to be many many
mortgage holders many many families
across the country who are now even more
worried about paying their mortgage
that's on top of all the other bills and
they know that the government's failed
now for 13 years they know the
government crashed the economy last year
the measures announced today will help
for now but fears remain that the relief
they provide will be temporary with
little sign of interest rates falling
anytime soon Matthew Thompson Sky News
Newport
a man who shot dead a Metropol
smuggling a gun into a holding cell has
been found guilty of murder his victim
Sergeant Matt ratano was described as a
gentle giant a warning for you that this
report by Sky's crime correspondent
Martin brunt includes the moments
leading up to Sergeant retana's shooting
you're just going to research mate
you're not under arrest I just need to
search her when police stopped and
searched Louis de zoyser in the early
hours they found seven bullets in his
coat pocket but they didn't discover
something even more deadly all right at
the police station Sergeant Matt retana
asked a Zoysia to stand up for a second
search
it was then the suspect somehow in
handcuffs produced an antique revolver
from a hidden holster and shot the
officer dead
as others grappled with to zoyser he
fired three more bullets he shot himself
and caused brain damage
Sergeant retana's partner was in court
to hear the guilty verdict today is
about the justice for Matt
life was taken too soon
in the line of duty doing a job that he
loved a cruel end for a lifetime of
service and dedication protecting others
the Met Police Commissioner said
Sergeant ratana made a lasting
impression on all who met him whether it
was on the streets or in the custody
Center as a uniform police officer
on the Rugby field or later as a coach
it's clear that he was someone who made
an enduring impact wherever he went the
men and women in policing daily stepping
forward into uncertainty and risk are
truly remarkable and deserve admiration
I'm Matt Ratner head coach
Matt retana was a New Zealander a rugby
fanatic and at 54 close to retirement
from the Met police
his killer Louis de zoyser is 25 a
talented data analyst at 13 he was
diagnosed with autism spectrum disorder
his lawyer argued the shooting was a
result of an autistic meltdown he hadn't
intended to harm the officer
in a wheelchair there's always a gave
evidence haltingly was asked simple
questions and gave one word answers now
police have quite limited powers when
this search a suspect on the street but
it still seems extraordinary that they
didn't find the revolver and he was able
to use it in handcuffs
just hold his jacket out for me the
independent office for police conduct
said the officers could have searched
the zoyser more thoroughly but they
didn't reach Professional Standards and
will face no charges or disciplines
the Watchdog has recommended that in
searches all forces make greater use of
metal detectors Martin brunt Sky News at
Northampton Crown Court
now the kakovka reservoir is the second
largest in Europe and is now dry
following the destruction of the
karkovka dam it should Supply a network
of canals providing irrigation for over
a million Acres of farmland farmland
which produces 2 million tons of grain a
year the destruction of the dam at Nova
kakovka has partially blocked a
potential Ukrainian river crossing in
the south of the country potentially
impacting their counter-offensive there
flood waters have also covered large
parts of the area south of herzen
displacing over 40 000 people to the
north of the dam this is what the
denipro river looks like in early June
but here are the images taken just three
days ago waterways that sustained over
700 000 people have been reduced to a
mere trickle our International Affairs
editor dommett Wagner waghorn has spoken
to those affected and he begins his
report in belenke before traveling to
the Village Reservoir
[Music]
it was Europe's second biggest Reservoir
but now looks more like a desert what
was a vast Lake for seven decades was
robbed of its water in just a few days
it's really sad and it's scary we just
want it to be like it used to be
Andrew is an engineer in charge of
pumping water out of the reservoir
sucked into these huge intakes can you
remember the moment that you heard the
dam had been blown up and what did you
think when you heard that yes I didn't
believe that something like that could
happen I can't believe that a human
brain can even consider that kind of
barbaric act I just can't believe that
in the pumping station just Birdsong
it's big Soviet era machine should be
pumping water at the rate of 4 million
liters an hour
not anymore
the water should be going into a vast
network of pipes and canals in the
months before Harvest
normally this canal is full of water at
a level way above my head it's
completely empty now and bone dry the
water is normally sucked into these big
pipes and taken out onto the fields over
a million Acres of Farmland on both
sides of the reservoir depend on these
canals for irrigation giving you an idea
of the scale of the disaster caused by
the dam being blown up
Ukraine may be famous for its rich black
soil but it's not much use without water
farmer Anton says his Harvest could be
cut by as much as two-thirds
if we had water and the irrigation work
we could Harvest 10 or 12 tons per
hectare but without it we'll be lucky to
get five it depends if it rains
but there's more to worry about here in
the distance zapparesian nuclear power
station the ukrainians say Russia has
now mined it and could blow up part of
it next
six miles for the plant on the Ukrainian
side of the reservoir the town of
maracanets
they've had no water in their Taps here
since the damn blue it's being trapped
in instead
it's very bad very bad I have a small
child and every day I need to carry at
least 12 of these bottles and they're
also deeply alarmed by what Vladimir
Putin plans to do now
of course I'm worried we're worried
about the nuclear power station we're
worried about just about everything
where should we go if something happened
at the plant water's okay we can cope
with that but if there's an explosion
over there what do we do
it
of course because there are a lot of
rumors the power plant is mined at any
point it could just blow we already have
no water in the river denipro and they
can easily just walk here
the reservoir is no longer a natural
defense against the enemy now it's been
reduced to Mud Flats the nuclear power
station menaces the town across its
rooftops and there's the question if
Russians could destroy a dam and a
reservoir what are they planning to do
here next Dominic wagorn Sky News
macronets
well we have some breaking news to bring
you tonight from Ukraine we're hearing
that the head of Russia's Wagner
mercenary group has accused Moscow of
destroying his Fighters our security and
defense editor Deborah Haynes is with us
and what more can you tell us Deborah
yes it's a fairly extraordinary
escalation in the vitriol between the
head of the Wagner mercenary group and
the Russian Ministry of Defense in a
series of of audio messages posted on
his telegram channel pagodian has
accused the Russian military of like you
said destroying his Fighters he's also
vowed to stop what he described as the
evil of the Russian military leadership
he said that his call for a March for
justice is not a military coup but the
Russian Security Services according to
Russian media have launched now a
criminal investigation into pagosian
um the Russian President Vladimir Putin
has been briefed about what has been
happening
um and in terms of the actual messages
from progression about his allegations
on one of their official
um Wagner telegram channels there's an
unconfirmed video and that shows what
they say is a a strike by a Russian
military strike against a Wagner base
saying that this is where Wagner
mercenaries were killed and pagosan also
accuses the Russian defense minister of
hiding the fact that 2 000 bodies of
Wagner mercenaries were being kept in a
morgue it's a very very serious
escalation the situation in Russia has
is obviously difficult to um to to to to
navigate but in terms of challenges to
the Russian leadership certainly the
Russian Ministry of Defense it's a
serious development that we will be
watching very closely okay Deborah for
now thank you
do you know doctors in England will
strive for five consecutive days next
month and what they say is the longest
single walkout in NHS history it marks a
dramatic escalation in their dispute
with government over pay and conditions
the British Medical Association has
called on ministers to produce a
credible payoffer the government though
says Junior doctors have turned their
backs on negotiations by announcing
further strikes
a Russian Diplomat is squatting on the
site of moscow's proposed Embassy in
Canberra after the Australian government
rejected the plan on National Security
grounds police are unable to arrest the
man due to his diplomatic immunity but
the Australian prime minister says he is
not a threat Sky's Nicole Johnston
reports
stand off unlike any other a man
described by local media as a Russian
Diplomat is holed up on a block of land
in Canberra
this block was meant to be home to
Russia's new Embassy but Australia
changed its mind it canceled the lease
last week passing emergency legislation
blocking Russia's plan to build an
embassy here
arguing it's a threat to National
Security too close to Parliament House
Russia called it an unfriendly display
by Australia and Russia phobic Hysteria
the man has been living on site since
Sunday
the national security threat
that was represented by a Russian
Embassy on site are not the same as some
bloke standing on a bladder grass on the
site that we don't see really as a
threat to our national security
just as well if he is a diplomat there's
little the police can do because he
could claim diplomatic immunity
Russia hasn't commented about the site's
new Resident but it's barred 48
Australians from traveling to Russia
and says it will take its case against
the ban on its lease to the high court
Nicole Johnston Sky News Sydney
the Arctic Monkeys are tonight's
headline acts at Glastonbury after its
lead singer Alex Turner made a last
minute recovery from laryngitis it's
another band though that's currently
making the headlines let's speak now to
Skies Katie Spencer who's there for us
tonight so who's the big surprise Katie
he might be able to hear in the distance
it's all got very noisy here because um
Alex Turner and the Arctic Monkeys have
begun within the last few minutes
they're they're much heralded uh
headline slot they weren't sure if he
was going to be able to make this
because of laryngitis he very much is
not sounding like a person with
laryngitis so I think it's well rested
and then it's done him some good and for
the thousands of people that are packed
out to see him good news no doubt but it
look it's not all about the Arctic
Monkeys that everyone's been talking
about today a little earlier than the
mystery was over the mystery was sold
we've been speculating wildly over the
last couple of weeks who the turn-ups
were the secret act that we were gonna
the big reveal was gonna happen today
and now we know it was the Foo Fighters
and Dave Grohl delivering very much a
set that was worthy of being a headline
slot in itself and we know in the past
of course they have headlines
Glastonbury but look if they were to
headline uh tonight or over the weekend
of course it wouldn't make a a
difference to one of the main talking
points of this glass Marine the fact
that is all the men that are getting the
prime slots uh here on the pyramid stage
it's something that people have been
talking about for weeks and weeks and
here's what some of the the Stars had to
say to us on that today
men men and more men as Glastonbury
campers settle into their temporary home
with Sir Elton Arctic Monkeys and Guns
and Roses bagging all of the best slots
on the pyramid stage there's quite a bit
at Glastonbury to unpack the big reveal
of the much hyped secret act listed as
the turn-ups not helping matters by
being another group of men the Foo
Fighters whose front man Dave Grohl was
seen arriving by train
the lack of women taking top spots comes
down to them having to work twice as
hard to make it I feel like women do get
a harder time like they critiqued a lot
more like for their body for their
weight for their you know what I'm
saying for a lot more I feel like males
get away with being a little bit more
basic women have to do a little bit more
as usual as we do in our normal lives we
have to do so much more
um but yeah that's that's the way it is
for now hopefully it'll change
Glastonbury co-organizer Emily Evis has
said the festival is looking to put two
female Headliners next year but it says
this situation has all come about
because of an industry pipeline problem
leading to a shortage of viable female
Headliners being developed
but according to the Lightning Seeds
front Manny and Brody it isn't the only
area the industry should look at with
streaming it's more about songs than it
is about albums and I think albums are
kind of what make big headline bands
it's almost like the Arctic Monkeys were
the last one through that gate almost
brag what's being sung matters just as
much as who's singing but you have a
song called sexuality so I've changed
the lyrics so it now says just because
you're they I won't turn you away if you
stick around I'm sure we can find the
right pronouns the trans Community need
cisgender people to stand up for them
for these Festival goers good music is
all that matters but to see a real
difference to who's on stage here the
industry needs to start dancing to the
same beat as those who are calling for
change Katie Spencer Sky News on worthy
Farm
well that was Sky News at 10 coming up
next a first look at domora's papers in
the Press preview including this stories
on the front of the mail tomorrow the
headline focusing on Jeremy Jeremy
Hunt's meeting with mortgage lenders
we'll be up there in just a few minutes
time tonight we have the columnist
Alison Morris and the former
conservative special advisor Anita
botang taking us through all the
newspapers we'll see in just a few
minutes
foreign
[Music]
hello everybody good evening you're
watching Sky News in a few minutes time
the Press previous coming up a first
look at what's on the front pages as
they arrive here at Sky News first
though let's remind you of our top
stories tonight Canadian investigators
have begun looking into what caused the
Titans submersible to implode killing
all five people on board mortgage
lenders have agreed measures to help
people struggling with repayments
including a 12-month grace period for
repossessions
and a 25 year old man has been found
guilty of murdering Sergeant Matt retana
who was shot dead in a met police
holding film
[Music]
hi there you are watching The Press
preview of first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive here at toys
at Sky News time to see what's making
the headlines with our fantastic guests
as well tonight Alison Morris call Miss
with the Belfast Telegraph joins as well
so does the former conservative special
advisor Anita patang very good to have
you both on the program thank you so
much for joining us tonight they'll be
with us from now until just before
midnight this evening let's have a look
what's on some of those front pages for
you now starting with the mail it leads
on mortgages with the headline mortgage
crisis hunt easing the pain in reference
to Jeremy Hunt striking a deal with
banks to help families hit by surging
mortgage repayments Jeremy Hunt's
mortgage pact also takes the lead for
the Ft tomorrow their headline reads
Banks to delay repossessions for 12
months onto the telegraph it also has
that story on their front cover quoting
Grant shapes with the headline
households spared 120 pound Net Zero
Levy
the times tomorrow leads with the claim
that millions of public sector workers
face having a pay rise is a six percent
blocked by the government amid mounting
concerns that they would fuel inflation
while the mirror reports on the doctor's
five-day strike saying Medics ramp up
action with the longest walkout in NHS
history UK hit by exempic shortages for
weight loss drug is the lead for the I
newspaper which reports on an
unprecedented demand in the popular
injection has led to supply issues on to
the guardian for you reporting on a
tsunami of dangerous Vapes flooding into
the UK
caring Prince's mission to honor Diana's
memory is the headline on the express
tomorrow morning reporting on Prince
William's Steely determination it says
to tackle homelessness in honor of his
late mother
invasion of the killer Hornets is the
daily Stars report on a horde of hornets
that could kill people with their stings
which are set apparently to invade
Britain
well a reminder that by scanning the QR
code that you see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch with us and of course we hope that
you do and of course I said earlier
we're tonight joined by Alison Morris
and Anita botany let's go and chat to
them now and start with some really
interesting front pages to get through
uh ladies very good evening to you and
welcome startless up the daily mail at
its front page mortgage crisis hunt
eases the pain of course uh well
documented in a meeting today with
Jeremy Hunt and some of the Britain's
biggest banks CEOs all are in number 11.
um what what do you make of the coverage
let's start with you Alice and how what
do you make of how the Daily Mail have
set it out
yeah well I mean it is interesting
because we had heard that there may have
been some sort of financial help to
people who are in mortgage crisis I
suppose much in the way that we had
those fuel payments
um during the winter months but instead
the The Daily Mail and a lot of the
other papers are reporting Jeremy Hunt's
plans he signed up a charter with some
of the major lenders so far HSBC at
Barclays have both signed up to this to
say that they will give people a minimum
of 12 months from the date of their
first default before they initiate and
repossession proceedings I think
currently it's around three months a
minimum of three months and then there's
other ideas such as letting people go
onto an interest only mortgage for six
months or let them extend the life of
their mortgage but all of that is
obviously just delay and they're sort of
putting the the problems down the road
about my own mortgage my fix rate ran
out
um two months ago and it has jumped by
115 pound a month
um which you know it'll be fine I'll
cope but I mean it's enough to put a lot
of people's you know lights out if
they're working there very tight budget
and a lot of people are in a lot worse
situations than that I know so many
people who are saying that their
mortgage payments have jumped so much
they're going to have to maybe get rid
of their car they're going to have to
make other massive Savings in order to
deal with it and the last thing the
government wants is a repeat of that
crisis of 2008 when we're seeing so many
people lost their homes as a result of
the financial crisis so clearly this is
all an attempt to try and make sure that
we don't have a repeat of what happened
there that's a huge amount of money
you're talking about Alison and we know
Anita that
2.4 million households are coming off
fixed rate mortgages next year of course
next year is an important year isn't it
politically because it's going to be a
general election year as well I mean do
you think that the conservative
government are doing enough when you
hear the likes of Labor saying it's a
weak response the liberal Democrats
saying it's a sticking plaster for a
gushing wound what do you think
well I think this is all very much
politics because the reality of the
situation is the government's proposal
and agreement with the lenders goes
further than what labor suggested for
instance
um around the kind of grace period they
wanted six months the the government has
agreed with the lenders a 12-month grace
period
um but the fundamental issue here that
the government is seeking to tackle
alongside the bank of England is high
inflation and inflation makes absolutely
everybody poorer and it has devastating
effects particularly on the most poor
and so you know increasing interest
rates which is very painful is A bank's
way of being able to reduce people's
spending power in order to get inflation
under control so the government is not
going to be able to counter counter
balance so what what the interest rates
are supposed to do by giving people more
money because that will not tackle the
core issue which is inflation so I think
there's quite a lot of politics here in
labor and liberal Democrats saying the
government isn't doing enough because
they they know that if the government
were to to sort of say well actually
we're going to make sure that people
have more financial help
um in the form of I don't know reduced
payments or payment to support that
would counter balance what the interest
rate Rises are supposed to achieve
um and so fundamentally I think what the
government is hoping is that in helping
the very very small number of people who
will be really deeply affected by this
so in terms of those mortgage rate of
payers who you know are in danger of you
know forbearance effectively so needing
this drastic help you keep that safety
net very strong in agreement with
lenders but you do allow interest rates
to stay where they are in order to
tackle inflation is the approach that
they're taking which makes sense to me
yeah well let's continue the discussion
and look at how other newspapers are
covering it the ft weekends front page
as you would imagine has got this as
their main story and and just reading a
bit further into that article Allison
that they they quote Pantheon economics
that forecast today that house prices
are going to fall 10 percent Peak to
trough after previously anticipating an
eight percent fall adding that they
expect the downtown to be drawn out with
prices not reaching the floor until the
beginning of 2024 I mean it's very Grim
news isn't it potentially
and it is and I mean this is an obvious
um it's an obvious knock-on effect from
what is happening financially everywhere
else because as the interest rate people
just can't afford mortgages but it also
means that people are stuck in a a sort
of rental cycle where they're paying
very high rent to live somewhere which
means they don't have any savings and it
means they'll probably never get on the
property ladder in their lifetime
um and this is all again I mean whether
or not they delay and part of this
obviously the repossession that they're
not allowed to start
um for building proceedings until 12
months but if you have a young family
and you're struggling it doesn't matter
whether you're gonna lose your house in
three months or 12 months you're going
to lose your home and that then pushes
up and pressure on the rental market as
well because there's just less homes and
more demand and the price of that goes
up so this has a massive knock-on effect
which will continue well after this
current crisis that we see ourselves in
into the years that come because as we
know from what happened in 2008 and 2009
and during that property bubble them on
all of that buster took it took a decade
for that just and this isn't going to be
something that's got to be resolved in a
year or two okay we're going to continue
the discussion in our 11 o'clock area on
Sky News let's have a look at some other
uh front pages now um Anita back to you
on the front page of the Daily Mirror
they choose a different story to go with
the news today that doctors are going to
go for a five-day strike five days in a
row we have to say next month to
coincide We Believe with the 70th
anniversary of the NHS and what do you
make of their coverage in this story
well yes as you say this is going to
have huge impact on the NHS and the
country at large um the mirror announces
that there's going to be this five-day
um strike from the 13th until the 18th
of July
um and that will obviously see thousands
of operations canceled this will be the
fourth strike um by Junior doctors in
England and
um you know the the fundamentals here of
the British Medical Association
um is asking for a 35 pay increase
um which the government says is
unaffordable
um and the labor
um Health secretary West cheating agrees
um and the government is offered a five
percent paid bump to uh offer to to end
the disputes so it does it looks like
the two sides are very very far apart
um and once again you're going to have a
situation where so many operations are
canceled and the knock-on impact on NHS
waiting lists will be you know loud and
clear yeah and and more misery for
patients as you say who have been
waiting long enough anyway on the NHS
um let's bring you back here Alison and
tie this with the front page of the
times because it does go quite well in
terms of their lead story that being a
potential pay blow for millions of
public sector workers the Times
newspaper says that millions of public
sector workers face having their pay
rise of six percent blocked by the
government amid mounting concerns that
they will fuel inflation of course we
know that that Junior doctors and nurses
are involved in that as well let me tell
us more
yeah I mean they're sending obviously
the government if they increase the the
pay which in terms of inflation most
people have have received what is an
effect of pay cut over the last five
years because inflation has increased
much quicker than especially those sort
of public sector wages have that people
it's going to fuel inflation just by
paying people a wage that they can
manage to survive on it's quite
short-sighted because if you look at
what the murderer said about the doctor
strike and then if you look at other
public services
um and other threats of strikes in
relation to that as well that costs so
much more than it would to try and
negotiate a decent pay pay raise for
those workers who are essential workers
these are the people we stood at doors
and we clapped for you know during the
the covert pandemic if they are paying a
decent wage that they're able then to go
to work we don't have these knock-on
strikes I mean that's obviously a saving
to the government and also a saving the
people especially those who are on
Hospital waiting list I live in a part
of the UK that has the highest win list
in the UK Northern Ireland Health
Services practically on its knees it
just is no longer a function and there's
no longer free healthcare at the point
of need because there is such a big
backlog and such long-witness and that
is something that you know in terms of
the longer not going to affect on
people's Health we know that the people
don't receive Health
um Healthcare and proper Healthcare when
they need it at that time but that
knocks on the more serious symptoms and
more serious illnesses which just in the
long run end up costing more money to
trade or ultimately that means that
people lose their lives prematurely so I
do think that you know the government's
going to have to come a bit further but
also some of those public sector unions
are maybe going to have to move back a
little bit in order to make the
government as well in order to resolve
this but just simply saying no we can't
give you our beliefs that you can live
on because it'll increase inflation I
don't think that that is a good enough
answer yeah it needs if we read into the
article a bit more it says ministers are
weighing up the private recommendations
from the pay review bodies and two
senior government sources have told the
newspaper they are likely to take the
rare step of overruling some of those
recommend I mean that's a bold move from
the government isn't it particularly
when they've already got a fight in
their hand with many public sector
workers
yes it is but I think we have to return
to the central issue which is inflation
now I'm not saying that the reason for
inflation is you know wage spiral like
that's not what I'm saying I'm saying
that actually we know the causes of
inflation were you know hugely Global
but the thing the government has to work
flat out to try to prevent is that
inflation becoming embedded deeply
embedded in the UK economy such that
everybody gets poorer in ways that is
you know can be potentially devastating
so the government is looking at doing
absolutely everything it can to Bear
down on some of the factors that can
increase inflation and so the
independent pay review bodies obviously
been an incredibly important part of the
negotiation and determining what kind of
recommendation makes sense taking into
account everything to do with the
economy but I think the government here
is the settings of managing some
expectations here there may need to be
some tough decisions taken and I don't
envy the government in this because they
absolutely want to retain and you know a
motivate staff they they know they have
challenges to deliver at the kind of
Public Services that people want but
they also know they have to manage and
tame the tiger of inflation or the pain
could get much much much worse and so
this is going to be dancing on a head of
a pin and really really difficult and
tense negotiations to come in a year
where you know the economy is already
you know when it looked when it comes to
the issue of inflation you know core
inflation remaining stubbornly High
um that there are the positive signs
that you might hope to see at this
moment um you know halfway through the
year and in a word Anita because we're
running out of time do you believe or do
you have faith that Richardson can halve
inflation by the end of the year as he
has promised to do
um I think that it's on a knife edge
okay thank you we'll leave it there
we'll come straight back to you after
this short break coming up next we're
going to look at this store it's on the
front page of the I newspaper tomorrow
UK hit by a zenpick shortages for weight
loss drugs we'll get more on that with
our columnists in just a few minutes
time see you shortly
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
independent United Kingdom
these last few years have seen some huge
stories
[Music]
and these stories have been driven by
politics by politicians the people in
power you must stay at home and it's my
job to figure out how these decisions
made by politicians impact all of us in
our everyday lives this is the worst
thing I've ever been through in my life
people turn up here with their child's
stuff in a black sack and just say I
don't wanna and that is what it is it's
first class poverty is this an example
of the welfare state failing
take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world these are stories
that affect us all
billions of children are now having to
catch up some stories have changed all
of our Lives because like the residents
the staff are being infected politicians
they make decisions all of the time and
it's our job to hold them to account I
wonder if you will take this opportunity
to apologize to those families but in
the end the real power doesn't actually
lie with the politicians
real power lies with the people
I'm Nick Martin I'm the people and
politics correspondent at Sky News
the pound has rallied moderation
interest rates peaking up and up at six
percent the highest for 14 years will
that be the peak will it be a little bit
lower prices it's closer to a potential
crash so many words so many meanings but
what do they mean for you and your
finances stay up to date on Sky News
[Music]
hello
foreign
[Music]
good evening to you you're watching the
Press preview with me tonight is the
columnist Allison Morris and the former
conservative special advisor Anita
botang great to have you both with us
tonight thanks so much for staying with
us and let's have a look at some of the
other Pages which are on the stories I
should say which were on the front pages
tomorrow and we're going to start with
the Telegraph and the telegraph ladies
actually has got a lot of Stories on its
front page tomorrow a very small one in
the kind of bottom left-hand corner it
looks like so Kia star my labor leader
has done an interview with the day
Telegraph Allison maybe he's trying to
win over their readers who knows says he
doesn't want to and he's going to try to
avoid increasing income tax if he wins
the election next year
yeah well I mean he's not going to find
his core vote you know what I'm doing
doing a do an interview sir but at the
same time too we know that there's an
action coming next year already we're in
full election mode and the polls are
shown at despite being quite a week
later of the opposition that um secure
Stormer is on track and we're saying
that to to uh have a a very small
possibly majority but certainly to be
able to form a government after the next
election that's the museum and for the
thing is you know he was it was has been
dealing with a complete turmoil that's
been happening in the conservative party
for the last year and that has no stable
eyes so he's up against it much more
stable prime minister and Rishi sinak so
a lot of that will be Financial because
we know that a lot of what's going to be
part of that election what's going to be
appealing to voters is dealing with the
kind of financial crisis as dealing with
inflation the cost of living
um the price of food and supermarkets
the price of fuel all of those sort of
things and so that is a I think he's now
gone for that sort of middle England
vote the folk that he lost um lot of in
the last general election
um but at the same time too a lot of
what I have seen from Clear Stormer a
lot of what he has said a lot of those
policies none of them are really very
substantially also in website baby at
the minute
um but we'll see how it goes but yeah
it's an interesting move you can see
that already they're already in full
election mode even though we've got
quite a bit of a time to go yeah I need
to let's get your views of course as a
former conservative special advisor do
you think so kirst armor if he becomes
prime minister could uh could maybe
could avoid increasing income tax the
top earners in this country what do you
think
uh no in a word um and it's interesting
that um the the headline says labor
won't raise top rate of tax but actually
what the what the story then says is
kusama said he does not want to increase
the top rated tax I think that labor is
grappling with a conundrum um that is
going to continue to bedevil it in the
next sort of year and a half which is
how do they set out a program that feels
genuinely new and exciting and offers
Solutions around whether it's you know
public sector investment and all of that
without making some pretty bold
commitments around how they're going to
pay for all of these um Innovations and
we've seen labor in recent weeks talk
about how it's not going to spend 28
billion pounds every single year the
minute it gets into power on their green
transformation but instead they're going
to ramp up to this amount of money and I
think that again they've accepted the
cost of borrowing are going up and
that's going to be expensive so I think
that this Dynamic around them showing
more lag Beyond with tiny amounts of tax
raising that they've talked about right
now is going to be quite important I'm
going to jump in just because we're
running out of time and I really want to
get to the front page of the eye
newspaper Allison to you first UK hit by
azimpic shortage this is the type 2
diabetes weight loss drug tell us more
very briefly
yeah and I think this is a lot of this
is fueled by celebrities people like
Elon Musk have said that they're using
the same thing you know there's a lot of
speculation at other
um very high profile celebrities have
been using this ambig to lose massive
amounts of weight and that obviously
filters down especially you know the
very sort of young men and women who are
maybe being influenced by that and so
it's created a shortage which means that
there's a shortage of the drug in terms
of what it's actually intended to do
what it was made for which was not as a
weight loss drug but as a joke for um
type 2 diabetics okay hold that thought
plenty more from both of you uh from 11
o'clock onwards do you stay with us
thank you so much for joining us uh
we're going to have a look at the
weather for you now for the weekend
ahead
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
a hot weekend for many people
particularly in the southeast of England
before things turn milder and more
mobile next week first thing on Saturday
it's going to be rather gray for many
areas most places are going to be dry
there will be a few outbreaks of rain
dotted around mostly in the west of
Scotland during the morning the cloud
will continue to come and go for many
places despite the cloud it's going to
be a really warm day tomorrow the
hottest weather is likely to be in the
southeast of England where temperatures
are expected to climb to 30 degrees
foreign
sponsored by Qatar Airways